bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant l'audition d'arnaud
montebourg et d'axel le maire devant la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat alors les ministres étaient
auditionnés sur des questions de
numérique et de téléphonie mobile le
ministre de l'économie et en particulier
revenu sur la nécessité selon lui de
revenir à trois opérateurs mobiles
arnaud montebourg qui incite donc les
opérateurs à chercher des rapprochements
selon les combinaisons qu'ils voudront
mais le ministre a également relativisé
les risques de remontée des prix du fait
de la présence de l'opérateur free sur
le marché voilà tout de suite donc
direction la salle médicis
monsieur le ministre nous sommes très
heureux le président val et moi même de
vous accueillir à l'issue d'un cycle
d'auditions
le nous peut-être collectif monsieur
jean bizet la sic de l'audition des
opérateurs de télécommunications
ce fut très riche d'ailleurs
d'enseignement pour nous y compris en
particulier l'audition de numericable de
ses fers
- peut-être l'audition de free et de oui
mais bon laurent je connaisse un peu
plus quand même déjà ces auditions sont
succédé alors que le secteur des
télécoms connaît des évolutions
importantes
nous souhaitons donc vous entendre sur
l'appréciation vous porter sur la
situation économique du secteur et des
opérateurs à court et moyen termes
selon vous d'ailleurs est ce que les
règles de la concurrence sont elles
respectées
la viabilité économique des opérateurs
suppose-t-elle une concentration de ceux
ci tel qu'on le voit se pointer par
ailleurs des investissements nécessités
par le déploiement de la fibre sont ils
effectivement réalisés et ne faut-il pas
revisiter le plan fille eux fibre avec
les nouvelles donnes de l'arrivée d'un
nouvel opérateur qui est numericable
avec une nouvelle technologie qui est
pas exactement ftth
de façon plus large et je vous écris ce
sujet la semaine dernière
ne pensez vous pas que le plan national
donc de très haut débit devrait être
actualisée pour tenir compte non
seulement des nouvelles configurations
mais de la nouvelle technologie
qu'imagine numericable en utilisant le
coc accents phase terminale
je vais donc laisser la parole au
président raymond vall pour ajouter
quelques mots notamment sur la
couverture numérique du territoire qui
constitue un an un enjeu primordial
pour nos collègues je ne peux pas passer
sous silence complètement une
proposition de loi
modération d'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques
qui m'occupe sérieusement depuis
quelques temps et donc je ne sais
toujours pas tout à fait comment
revisiter les termes de cette
sédimentation de compromis qui qui ont
conduit un texte sorti de l'assemblée
nationale qui comme d'habitude constitue
un brouillon que nous devons mettre au
propre
non mais attends il ya des choses
redondantes et contradictoires donc il
va falloir trouver des solutions et en
particulier en sémantique sur les
équipements terminaux des équipements
radioélectriques parce que c'est tout
cela et ne ménagent qu'on doit faire là
dedans vient ensuite bien sûr la
priorité sera donnée
aux groupes d'étude postes et
télécommunications
et qui vous opposeront les premières
questions puis bien sûr ceux de mes
collègues qui voudront vous interrogez
je crois que vous soyez obligés de
passer sous silence non plus les
négociations entre general electric et
alstom affamant mais je vous laisse
libre des fautes l'expression monsieur
le ministre
vraiment en ce qui est intéressant avec
le président raul c'est qu'une fois
qu'il a parlé tout a été dit monsieur le
ministre donc sachez qu'il est très
heureux aussi avec les membres de la
commission durable de vous accueillir et
c'est sous l'aspect de
compétences que nous interrogerons bien
sûr sur l'avancée de ce blanc et puis
les difficultés qu'on peut avoir sur le
terrain
puisqu'un certain nombre de schémas qui
sont bien avancés qui ont reçu des
accords et on a ici le président de
l'avicca qui ne manquera pas d'en parler
avec une vision nationale donc c'est
vrai quand s'interroge aussi sur le fait
de savoir si on ne peut pas dans
certains territoires
vraiment utiliser optimisée des
infrastructures qui existe et qui est
parfois n'apparaissent pas sur les
schémas on a beaucoup de mal à exhumer
cesser ces films qui sont dans ces
territoires et qui parfois pourrait
simplifier c'est chez nous tous sommes
en parlerons tout à l'heure et comme le
temps nous est compté je préfère tout de
suite
vous donnez la parole monsieur liste
merci
bonjour
merci messieurs les présidents et
messieurs les sénateurs
peut-être pour répondre
aux préoccupations
soulevées par vos interventions sur le
secteur des télécoms
peut-être pourrais-je résumé la
situation
en disant qu'
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
résorber les effets de nature
sismique de l'arrivée
d'un nouvel opérateur
qui s'appelle free qui est une décision
qui a été prise
dans des conditions qui peuvent
parfaitement justifié politiquement mais
dont les conséquences n'ont pas été
anticipées
est-ce que cela revient à condamner tel
ou tel opérateur est parti hier mon
celui à la réponse est non puisque ce
sont les pouvoirs publics qui ont décidé
de procéder en par l'intensification de
la concurrence considérant que la
concurrence devait tenir lieu de
politique tout court ce qui n'est pas la
position du gouvernement auquel j'ai
l'honneur d'appartenir la concurrence
est parfois nécessaire
parfois elle n'est pas elle est
contreproductive
elle est destructrice
l'idéologie de la politique industrielle
passant par la concurrence
parfois et destructrices comme toute
idéologie donc il faut être pragmatique
équilibré raisonnable donc nous pouvons
constater un premier effet c'est que
les prix
sont descendus
c'est donc un avantage pour le
consommateur il faut le reconnaître et
s'en féliciter puisque c'est un avantage
important mais cette situation n'est pas
durable elle est même dangereux s'il
venait à se prolonger pour quelle raison
parce que quand vous avez finalement
des opérateurs qui font une offre
de services qui se font une concurrence
déchaînée par les prix déclenchant une
guerre des prix qu'on n'a pas connues
amenant la france à être un des pays
peut être le pays où les prix sont les
plus bas au monde
avec peut-être je crois israël qui ont
comparé les services puisque ce sont
toujours des services différenciés
distincts et donc nous avons une
situation où les prix sont les plus bas
et donc nous avons des dégâts sociaux et
économiques industrielles nous avons
assisté à une accélération des
délocalisations de centres d'appels
à
la recherche du low cost chez les
équipementiers
de par les opérateurs dans leurs
équipements télécoms c'est l'arrivée de
huawei et de surtout de huawei sur le
marché européen au détriment d'alcatel
sont quand même des conséquences que
nous avons payées en termes de plans
sociaux même si ce n'est pas la cause
unique des difficultés d'alcatel nous
avons
connu aussi une remise en question du
système servicielle qui était notamment
les boutiques la distribution des
services qui étaient attachées aux
anciens opérateurs donc vous avez eu des
dégâts sur
l'économie du service avec des
destructions d'emplois je prends
l'exemple de phone house qui a dû être
liquidés
et puis des plans sociaux chez les
opérateurs il n'a eu un chez sfr ils ont
été généreusement indemnisés ce qui
explique on a peu entendu parler mais
ils ont existé chez bouygues telecom il
y en a déjà eu un et un autre semble
être annoncée est beaucoup plus
important que le précédent
donc si à chaque fois qu'on déclenche la
concurrence son intensification
nous subissons une guerre des prix
destructrice
qu'est ce que finalement on a obtenu le
consommateur a gagné mais finalement le
producteur est en train de disparaître
donc ce n'est pas un bon équilibre donc
il faut le rétablir
je veux d'ailleurs donné quelques
indications sur les problèmes liés aux
investissements
si nous avons 20 milliards à mettre dans
la fibre à la maison comme on dit ftth
il n'y a pas 36 solutions soit sont les
opérateurs qui investissent parce que
c'est leur intérêt ou parce qu'ils le
peuvent
soit s'ils ne le peuvent pas alors que
c'est leur intérêt parce que ils ont des
marges trop écrasé les prix maintiennent
la pression sur leur investissement et
bien c'est les contribuables qu'il
faudra une nouvelle fois sollicités donc
nous avons à trouver le bon équilibre
parmi le dans le secteur voilà pourquoi
depuis deux années que j'ai en charge ce
secteur
je j'ai multiplié les déclarations
toujours concordantes
expliquant que la situation européenne
de manière général n'était pas
acceptable et pas seulement française
combien yat-il d'opérateur pour les 300
millions de clients américains 3
3 me avec les consolidation en cours
combien utile d'opérateur pour les 800
millions de clients chinois de et demi 3
combien y at-il de d'opérateur pour les
400 millions d'européens 120
balkanisation émiettement de l'offre
affaiblissement les opérateurs combien
yat-il d'opérateurs européens en bonne
santé bonne question je ne me
permettrais pas de donner un chiffre
mais fait cette analyse allez voir les
comptes de tous les opérateurs européens
et vous verrez ce que l'idéologie
obstiné obsessionnelle de la mise en
concurrence y compris par les
infrastructures
qu'est ce que la concurrence par les
infrastructures c'est celle qui consiste
à
dire aux opérateurs vous pouvez
multiplier les équipements qui sont en
double en triplant ou quadruplant
parfois ça n'a pas d'importance et vous
pouvez donc abandonner les zones peu
denses parce que là il ya pas de clients
donc finalement on se retrouve dans une
situation c'est dans cette guerre la
privatisation des quelques profits qui
reste est la nationaliser s'ils ont des
pertes qu'il faut que néanmoins assumé
est comblé donc cette stratégie sur le
plan européen est une stratégie qui ne
nous convient pas j'ai noté des éléments
d'inflexion depuis un certain nombre de
mois d'abord nous avons avec fleur
pellerin lorsqu'elle était ministre
délégué saisi l'autorité de la
concurrence qui a
admis la nécessité
l'utilité en termes d'intérêt général de
faire cesser
la concurrence par les infrastructures
en permettant la mutualisation
des moyens des missions
télécommunications permettant une sorte
de partage du territoire c'est à vis de
la concurrence qui a maintenant un an
nous permet de fonder juridiquement un
certain nombre d'évolutions
dans les mentalités des différents
opérateurs et y compris les autorités de
la concurrence européenne nous attendons
une décision je crois au mois de juin
sur la situation
allemande
de la commission européenne la direction
de la concurrence je crois qu'il ya un
autre cas d'ailleurs y'a pas pardon et
l'irlande voilà j'avais peur de me
tromper
ce sont des décisions qui peuvent en
effet montré
une évolution de la doctrine européenne
en la matière et elle serait la
bienvenue
donc notre la position du gouvernement
c'est le maire vient d'arriver
travaillent avec moi sur ces sujets
c'est une position consistant à
favoriser la consolidation je veux dire
aux actions aux associations de
consommateurs comme aux parlementaires
que vous n'êtes que la consolidation et
le retour à trois opérateurs n'est pas
synonyme d'entente il ya des ententes à
quatre et il peut y avoir de la
concurrence à 3 il y a eu des ententes
qui ont d'ailleurs été à juste titre
sanctionné par l'autorité de la
concurrence sur des faits qui remontent
à 10 ans à l'époque des trois opérateurs
orange historique france télécom c'est
faire eh oui
nous imaginons que le maintien le free
qui est un peu le le disruptif des trois
opérateurs maintiendra une pression sur
les prix tout en favorisant un
renforcement une consolidation de nos
opérateurs au plan national
préparant la consolidation au plan
européen que nous appelons aux
gouvernements de nos voeux et sur
laquelle nous travaillons en laissant
bien sûr les opérateurs mené leur
opération ne sommes pas intrusif dans
leurs choix stratégiques même si nous
sommes intéressés par les décisions
qu'il qu'il prendrait j'ai noté que le
rapprochement sfr numericable
n'a pas permis cette consolidation à 3
donc le problème reste que je viens
d'évoquer les problèmes que j'ai
évoquées restent devant nous et c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
incitent publiquement les opérateurs à
chercher les voies et les moyens d'un
rapprochement autant qu'ils le pourront
selon les combinaisons qu'ils voudront
bien eux-mêmes
imaginé voilà je crois en termes résumé
ce que je peux indiquer
la chambre la haute lâchant la haute
assemblée sur
les poids qui sont en
discussion publique
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
et je vous en prie bienvenue d'abord au
sénat pour votre première venue
si beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
excusez moi pour mon retard en fait le
bizutage a déjà eu lieu puisque je sors
d'une précédente audition concernant la
gouvernance de l'internet et c'est ce
qui explique ce qui explique la raison
de mon demande retard les cultureux sont
toujours beaux leur contenu
n'a pas douté
donc je ne sais pas ce qui a été dit
j'espère ne pas ne pas me répéter avec
arnaud montebourg
mais je pense que la raison de cette de
cette convocation
elle est toute légitime c'est face au
constat de possibles concentration dans
le secteur des télécoms français face
aux annonces d'une réforme des
territoires qui oblige à poser la
question du rôle des départements qui
ont un rôle fondamental
notamment dans la mise en oeuvre du plan
france très haut débit désormais face à
la réorganisation
institutionnelle des régions des
questionnements
s'exprime pour savoir dans quelle mesure
et c'est ce dont je serai amené à parler
sans doute plus spécifiquement le plan
france très haut débit le déploiement
d'internet en très haut débit sur les
territoires français peut être remise en
cause plus spécifiquement à mon sens
deux questions que j'estime et encore
tout à fait légitime de la part des élus
de manière générale et des
parlementaires en particulier que sont
dans la zone amis qui la zone des 50 3%
ou les opérateurs privés sont autorisés
à déployer la fibre optique dans le
cadre de contrats passés avec l'état et
les collectivités territoriales
est-ce que des concentrations dans le
secteur des télécoms
vont remettre en cause les engagements
d'investissement
acquis de la part des opérateurs
télécoms c'est en particulier le cas
pour les zones câblées
puisque le très haut débit est
dans une certaine partie déjà présents
et que certains opérateurs pourraient
être tentés du fait du jeu de la
concurrence des infrastructures de
déployer tout de même la fibre et puis
la question des zones blanches qui reste
un sujet et là aussi tout à fait
légitime est-ce que les
47% de zones où ces où ce sont les
autorités publiques et les collectivités
locales qui ont le rôle d'intervenir
pour assurer le déploiement du très haut
débit et bien dans ces zones est ce que
le plan très haut débit sera remise en
cause est-ce que l'investissement de
l'état et des collectivités
est menacée ce qui menacerait
potentiellement l'engagement du
président de la république de déployer
la fibre optique à l'échelle des
territoires d'ici
2023 eh bien je pense qu'il faut à la
fois être lucide sur la situation et en
même temps la relativiser pour ne pas
inquiéter ni les consommateurs ni les
investisseurs nous sommes à une période
charnière où il faut être en mesure de
continuer à convaincre les opérateurs de
venir investir sur nos territoires
l'état s'est engagé très fortement à
hauteur de 3,3 milliards d'euros de
subventions c'est le plus grand chantier
d'infrastructures de ce début du siècle
c'est le grand chantier d'infrastructure
du quinquennat toutes les études
économiques prouve que l'arrivée du très
haut débit et à une corrélation directe
avec la création de valeur économique et
donc la croissance et la création
d'emplois
et de ce constat il n'est pas que si on
de remettre en cause l'engagement de
l'état pour le plan français très haut
débit l'engagement de l'état et
l'engagement des opérateurs dans la
mesure où ce sont déjà trois milliards
d'euros qui ont été investis en l'espace
de peu de temps par les opérateurs des
télécoms en france pour le déploiement
dans le cadre de ce plan c'est un plan
qui a un cadre souple qui s'appuie avant
tout sur le dialogue entre les acteurs
des allocs qui est animé par la mission
france très haut débit hébergés
bercy et qui fait ses preuves il n'est
plus question d'une opposition principe
yale entre d'une part les opérateurs et
de l'autre les collectivités locales
avec l'état qui se poserait en arbitre
désormais le dialogue primes et cela est
efficace puisque un certain nombre de
projets notamment deux départements ont
déjà été validées et des accords de
principe des engagements de l'état
trouvez donc le cadre de ce plan très
haut débit les souple puisque il permet
aux opérateurs privés de mettre en
commun leurs capacités financières au
service de la construction de nouvelles
infrastructures en fibre optique et il
est aussi souple parce qu'il permet aux
opérateurs privés et aux collectivités
de couvrir le plus rapidement possible
les zones prioritaires
qu'elle soit dans les zones qui seront
couvertes par les opérateurs privés ou
par ces collectivités
zones prioritaires et au premier rang
desquels les écoles et avec arnaud
montebourg et benoît hamon nous avons
récemment lancé le plan école connectés
puisque nous avons tout à fait
conscience de la nécessité d'avoir des
écoles qui ont accès à internet pour
assurer
l'enseignement
numérique de nos enfants alors cette
démarche de dialogue elle porte ses
fruits je les 10 54 dossiers déposés à
ce jour pour un soutien au titre du fsn
qui permettront d'offrir 4 millions à 4
millions de foyers là c'est au très haut
débit et à 600 mille foyers un meilleur
débit par la réalisation d'opérations de
montée en débit sur le réseau de cuivre
c'est la thune demandes répétées de la
part de certains élus c'est vrai que moi
quand je me déplace dans les territoires
on me dit vous savez le très haut débit
par la fibre au fond nous ce qu'on veut
c'est internet et c'est effectivement
quelque chose que le gouvernement doit
être en mesure d'entendre et donc nous
ne refusons pas par principe l'idée d'un
mix technologique par pragmatisme et par
mesure de réalisme au vu de l'urgence à
combler la fracture numérique pour
autant il n'y a aucune remise en cause
de l'objectif politique affichée dès
2012 et l'arrivée au pouvoir du
président de la république qui est le
déploiement du choix technologiques qui
a été et qui a été
opérée par la france qui est celui du
déploiement de la fibre optique le
volume global d'investissements au total
correspond à 7 milliards d'euros à ce
jour ce qui signifie que 3,2 millions de
logements peuvent
accéder au très haut débit dont 600
milles hors des zones les plus denses du
territoire une dynamique a été initié
elle est engagée il faut veiller à ne
pas enrayer
donc le gouvernement est vigilant à ce
que la concentration qui vient d'avoir
eu lieu dans le fixe bénéficier à tous
et que les à gand les engagements qui
ont été annoncées lors du rachat de sfr
soit mise en oeuvre cela signifie 450
millions d'euros supplémentaires de la
part de sfr numericable en 2015 2016
2017 dans le plan france très haut débit
pour les zones denses et 50 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour amorcer
l'arrivée des grands fournisseurs
d'accès à internet sur les réseaux
publics le gouvernement restent très
vigilants à ce que ces engagements
d'investissement dans le plan france
très haut débit soit respectée nous
travaillons également avec les acteur
sur les conditions qui permettront à la
dynamique en cours de s'accélérer au
profit des territoires pour cela il faut
tu adapter l'environnement réglementaire
notamment sur l'accès aux immeubles pour
la fibre afin que la réglementation
applicable à la fibre ne soient pas
pénalisantes par rapport à d'autres
moyens technologiques il faut aussi
permettre la constitution de montage
avec des investisseurs de long terme
pour accompagner l'accélération de
l'investissement des opérateurs
le gouvernement y réfléchit
comment permettre que la concurrence
entre infrastructures se fasse au
bénéfice des usagers
et
non pas au détriment des engagements
d'investissements de la part des
opérateurs
donc le plan doit permettre de répondre
à des besoins prioritaires d'abord il
fait pourtant un effort particulier pour
le raccordement des entreprises et des
services publics j'ai déjà parlé des
écoles et il apporte des réponses
ciblées aux certains besoins en prenant
partie du mix technologique en recourant
notamment à des solutions de montée en
débit pour apporter une réponse rapide
dans les territoires les moins
favorisés voilà pour un aperçu
d'ensemble de la démarche du
gouvernement qui sont consiste non pas à
remettre à plat le plan france très haut
débit bien au contraire à rassurer les
usagers comme les opérateurs sur la
volonté du gouvernement d'atteindre dans
les temps l'objectif qui a été visée il
faut simplement tenir compte à la fois
des conséquences possibles de la
concentration du secteur comme de la
réforme des territoires sur ce plan est
donc en particulier de trouver des
outils de financement qui soit peut-être
innovant dans le paysage des télécoms et
qui permettent de répondre à des besoins
spécifiques notamment ceux identifiés
sur les zones
les zones denses je me tiens à votre
disposition pour répondre à des
questions et notamment au rôle que
pourraient jouer les grandes plateformes
numériques
dans ce nouveau paysage des télécoms et
paysage institutionnel français
merci madame la ministre je vais donner
la parole à monsieur pierre hérisson co
président du groupe d'études postes et
télécommunications et peut-être à la
suite au président de l'avicca s'il veut
que ses deux premières interventions
soient couplées mais madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre je vous avais écrit
justement parce que suite aux
différentes auditions nous nous sommes
posé des questions est ce que on ne doit
pas revisiter sans parler des objectifs
qui doivent rester les mêmes vues la
technologie qu'on nous a développé en
tous les cas lors des auditions par
numericable sfr est ce qu il n'y a pas
des priorités
changé dans les zonages et et renfermant
on en reste là pour le moment
je suis persuadé que monsieur p pierre
hérisson
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la ministre
je crois que nous pouvons
quelles que soient nos sensibilités
politiques ici souscrire à l'essentiel
de ce que vous avez dit et là et l'autre
je serais tenté de dire pour être ici
dans en charge et en différentes
responsabilités de ce sujet depuis 1996
d'avoir connu
des étapes plus ou moins inquiétantes
vous en avez rappelé une totale
autonomie c'est l'autorisation qui a été
donnée au quatrième opérateur
qui a eu pour effet catastrophique de
diminuer ou de de diminuer de
l'essentiel de leurs capacités
d'investissement les opérateurs
l'opérateur historique et les nouveaux
entrants et puis
l'évolution technologique qui nous a
éloignés de certaines idéologies pour
nous amener à ce que j'appellerai
à la suite
de l'audition des quatre opérateurs et
de la rencontre que nous avons avec vous
ce soir de dire que le bon sens est en
train de l'emporter sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui étaient beaucoup
trop
orienté vers le tout ou rien j'en
voudrais pour preuve
le courrier que nous avez adressé en son
temps je crois que c'est au mois de
septembre
2013 de madame fleur pellerin qui dans
un paragraphe de sa lettre dit tout
simplement il y a la fibre optique bien
sûr mais il y a aussi les autres
technologies et je crois qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une logique de
complémentarité pour assurer la
couverture du territoire et que la
promesse électorale qui a été fait par
les deux principaux qu'un candidat en
tout cas celui deuxième tour à
l'élection présidentielle l'un proposant
la fibre de bout en bout sur le
territoire en 12 ans et l'autre en
disant
nous avait éloigné un peu
de notre capacité d'investissement de la
réalité et d'une réalité qui est plus
qu'évidente qui consiste sans
s'enferrant rappel qui remontera la
préhistoire mais de rappeler que la
france par son service universel qui est
toujours en vigueur aujourd'hui et qui
est
maintenue par l'opérateur historique a
réalisé la totalité on va l'appeler du
cuivre ajout lui je sais pas quels mots
ils font payer mais enfin du réseau
cuivre qui permet le service universel
sur notre territoire dans un échange
donnant donnant avec le monopole et si
france télécom en son temps a pu
réaliser sans aide publique à
l'exception de la mise en souterrain des
réseaux qui a pour l'essentiel étaient
portés par les collectivités on peut
dire que tout ça s'est réalisé avec
l'argent des consommateurs certes il
n'était pas considéré tout à fait comme
tel à l'époque du monopole et que
l'évolution
curieusement alors que les opérateurs
sont aujourd'hui sur le marché de la
concurrence du privé on voit arriver une
obligation qui pourrait être fait
d'assurer la couverture d'une partie
presque 70% du territoire donc le de
leurs en dehors des eaux dhabi et qui
devrait être couverte avec de l'argent
public et je crois que le moment est
venu d'avoir un peu plus de réalisme sur
ce projet et que la priorité ça doit
être de trouver les moyens de donner les
moyens aux opérateurs d'assurer la
couverture et l'ensemble des réseaux du
territoire par tout cela est possible et
de laisser des collectivités en
complémentarité de ce qui peut être ce
qui ne peut être fait par l'
équilibre économique des opérateurs et
non pas l'inversé dans lequel nous nous
sommes un peu peut-être trop vite
s'engager à considérer que les réseaux
d'initiative publique était au même
niveau que les obligations des
opérateurs alors que pour moi et pour
beaucoup d'entre nous les collectivités
sont là pour assurer une accélération ou
un délai plus court de réalisation de
couverture du territoire je pense que
sur ce plan là il faut corriger me
semble-t-il les objectifs alors sans
vouloir être trop long mon collègue
bruno retailleau également spécialiste
dans ce dossier
qui ne peut pas être là cet après midi
et pour en avoir discuté entre nous nous
avons une question la première question
elle a déjà largement été évoquée par
vous même et qui conserve qui consiste
évidemment à voir si le plan national du
très haut débit doit être remise en
cause ou tout du moins
modifier corrigé réorienter
surtout avec l'arrivée de du projet de
fusion des deux opérateurs et d'une
situation un peu à l'allemande si vous
m'autorisez cette comparaison puisque
les allemands n'ont pas choisi la fibre
ce qui ne les empêche pas de déployer de
la fibre mais utilise le coaxial pour le
parcours ce terminal qui leur permet
très rapidement beaucoup plus rapidement
de couvrir avec un débit raisonnable de
50 il y habite moyen sur l'essentiel du
territoire avec une particularité qu'ils
n'ont pas à gérer c'est que la france
est dans une situation de 80 ans en deux
populations sur le territoire 80% sur
20% du territoire et par voie de
conséquence linverse ils sont dans une
situation de 40/60 de présence sur le
territoire qui est plus facile à mettre
en oeuvre pour les équilibres
économiques dans ma première question
c'est le plan national du très haut
débit dans quelle mesure et compte tenu
des éléments nouveaux comptez vous
l'aurez orienté et puis la deuxième
question elle va à une proposition que
fait bruno retailleau maintenant depuis
un certain temps la constitution la
constitution pardon d'une agence
numérique idée défendue depuis longtemps
par lui et par d'autres dans cette
maison et qui avait été proposé à la
meuf leurs pèlerins en son temps c'est à
dire début de l'année 2013 voilà ce que
je pouvais dire comme co président du
groupe d'étude sur
numérique et plus particulièrement sur
le déploiement des réseaux et madame la
ministre madame le maire merci de de
l'exposé tout à l'heure que vous avez
fait devant une autre commission sur la
gouvernance internet je crois que pour
avoir été plusieurs fois aux états unis
sur ce sujet vous avez parfaitement
intégré les difficultés de cette
opération et je tenais à vous en
remercier
merci monsieur rome bien merci je
ministres secrétaires d'état messieurs
les présidents chers collègues je ne
partagerais pas bien entendu
complètement vous l'avez compris
l'analyse de pierre hérisson bien que
j'ai longtemps travaillé à ses côtés sur
les causses faire du numérique je me
retournerais vers mon collègue le roi
qui en son temps a permis aux
collectivités territoriales d'agir dans
le déploiement des réseaux numériques et
nous en sommes quasiment au dixième
anniversaire et je dirais messieurs les
ministres à la croisée des chemins
le plan national très haut débit a
produit des effets très largement
positif
puisque a aujourd'hui
64 collectivité vous l'avez souligné
madame ministres ont adopté un schéma
d'aménagement numérique une dizaine
d'entre elles ont passé des marchés
subséquents de l'ordre de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros par
département pour déployer des réseaux
cela a été rendu possible grâce à
l'accélération du plan france national
très haut débit qui a mobilisé
aujourd'hui les 900 millions d'euros qui
étaient disponibles au titre du grand
emprunt et qui aujourd'hui en fait sont
largement dépassé puisque
il s'agit de plus d'un milliard d'euros
qui
font l'objet d'attribution aux
collectivités territoriales quand je dis
que nous sommes à la croisée des chemins
j'ai bien entendu des propos positifs de
madame le maire qui met indique qui nous
a déjà indiqué c'est la deuxième fois au
moins dans des lieux intéresser aux
sujets à la sécurisation des 3 milliards
via nul 3 millions d'euros pour
poursuivre le déploiement du franc du
plan france très haut débit sauf que
aujourd'hui mon collègue le roi comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues n'ont pas
trouvé trace un corps dans les lignes
budgétaires
des lois de finances de ses engagements
il ya donc nécessité à consolider par
des engagements précis sur les lois de
finance les engagements de l'état pour
que les collectivités territoriales qui
frappe on sait déjà au guichet du fonds
de la société numérique puisse trouver
mes instructions une issue positive à
leur dossier donc croisée des chemins
parce qu'il faut consolider parce qu'il
faut aussi comme l'a répété ce triste à
juste titre par dont moi aussi j'arrive
à me tromper comme l'a fait le ministre
à l'avicca sur le désir
il faut également consolider
les opérateurs qui nous partageons
l'analyse du trouble apportée par
l'introduction du quatrième opérateur
qu'il faut consolider la filière si on
veut la rendre plus efficace et si on
veut aussi surtout que les opérateurs
puissent tenir les engagements qu'ils
ont contractualisé sur les zones amis et
leur difficulté de dégager des
investissements nécessaires je le sais
doit vous interpellez je voudrais poser
la première question qu en est il des
véhicules financiers
susceptibles d'être mobilisés au profit
des opérateurs pour qu'ils puissent
tenir leurs engagements sur les zones
amie lizanne ont le plus grand besoin
aujourd'hui ensuite je reviendrai sur le
terrain qui m'est le plus cher celui des
collectivités territoriales mon cher
pierre un indiquant que les évolutions
de la réforme territoriale
inquiète au plus haut niveau
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales qui se sont engagés et ont
mobilisé des fonds
significatif et qui enquêtent décret et
certaines structures donc leur
inquiétude est double à la fois en
termes financiers quelle sera leur
devenir est essentiellement aussi en
matière de gouvernance qu'en sera-t-il
des syndicats mixtes ouverts que la
plupart des collectivités
départementales ou régionales ont mis
sur pied pour accompagner l'effort du
gouvernement
quand on sait que les frontières entre
départements appelé selon
l'information du matin à disparaître
dans un délai aujourd'hui fixés dans les
engagements
l'engagement des régions qui elle même
sont bouleversés dans leur architecture
et je ne voudrais pas la couche des
intercommunalités qui sont mêmes appelé
à bouger simplement monsieur le ministre
je voudrais déjà signalé de nombreuses
reprises cet objectif que seuls les
opérateurs privés ne pourront jamais
atteindre pour que l'objectif
présidentiel ceux tenus il faut que
l'ensemble des échelons territoriaux se
mobilisent jeu c'était quand même un
exemple la plupart des projets que l'on
analyse bénéficient des fonds du feder
bénéficient des fonds de la société
numérique bénéficie de la mobilisation
des financements régionaux bénéficie de
l'engagement des départements 64 d'entre
eux sont engagés le sujet mais ce n'est
pas suffisant au parveniez à l'
équilibre financier il faut appeler
l'échelon communal ou intercommunal
donc vous comprenez bien que les
évolutions qui sont devant nous risque
d'inquiéter de retarder de freiner
l'appétence de bon nombre de
collectivités et donc retarder la tenue
de ces objectifs j'aurai une deuxième
question j'ai entendu que vous évoquez
les négociations avec bruxelles
j'aimerais connaître quel sera le sort
réservé au feder qui est indispensable
aussi également à la tenue des objectifs
et puis aussi vous avez abordé les
difficultés liées aussi à la
notification européenne d investissement
parfois des collectivités sur le l efo
zone aujourd'hui réservé à l'opérateur
historique voilà monsieur le ministre je
réitère mon propos nous sommes à la
croisée des chemins les collectivités
territoriales ont besoin d'être
sécurisés dans l'engagement massif
qu'elles ont opéré sur cette priorité
affichée par le président de la
république
bien
madame monsieur le mini les ministres
la parole est à celui qui la demande
nous qui la prends c'est axel le maire
qui chargé
dans l'organisation de deux du ministère
de mettre en oeuvre le plan très haut
débit et je l'en remercie parce que
c'est un travail considérable très
important plus c'est important d'écouter
les territoires le représentant que vous
êtes je voudrais peut-être dire deux
mots avant de lui laisser la parole pour
qu'elle entre dans le détail sur
l'esprit dans lequel nous travaillons
nous souhaitons faire aboutir ce plan
thd ça vous a été dit par moi-même à
l'avicca ça vous été dit à l'instant par
madame axel le maire nous souhaitons
faire bondir les événements dans
l'ordre de
des opérateurs qui n'ont pas terminé de
se produire ne doivent pas affecter
notre détermination
donc nous avons une vision pragmatique
de ce projet qui est ambitieux et nous
souhaitons donc nous
avons notre cap le chemin les moyens la
marche en avant et y compris les
réformes de toute nature ne doivent pas
perturber cet objectif c'est une
mobilisation nationale c'est la
compétitivité du pays qui est en jeu
c'est la capacité dans un pays qui
s'interroge beaucoup sur
son sa géographie son espace et son
utilisation spatiale pourquoi parce que
nous avons une démographie en croissance
considérable par rapport à d'autres pays
européens nous avons aujourd'hui un
exode urbain qui se note dans les
campagnes on a connu dans moi dans mon
enfance
d'autres dans leur adolescence
des exodes ruraux
et aujourd'hui vous avez 10 millions de
français qui déclarent vouloir partir
vivre à la campagne le plus entassés
dans les métropoles et les villes donc
il est évident pour la compétitivité de
notre pays
la mutation des modes de travail des
changements de société la révolution
numérique en cours vous n'aurez pas que
des êtres humains plusieurs milliards
d'entre eux sont déjà connectés sur
internet vous allez avoir 50 milliards
d'objets qui vont être connectés sur
internet puis on dans l'environnement du
quotidien où il sera possible de
s'éduquer à distance de se soigner à
distance de travailler à distance bref
de vivre autrement la france dispose
d'atouts extraordinaire c'est la raison
pour laquelle le plan thd est pour nous
un objectif stratégique donc prêt forme
du département modification de la carte
des régions consolidation des opérateurs
nous prendrons les moyens pour ne pas se
démobiliser
voilà et quand en effet les remarques
ont été faites sur oust et le public ou
le privé je vais vous dire quand on va
consolider à 3 on va donner de la force
aux opérateurs c'est bien en
contrepartie on va leur demander de
pousser les limites on va pousser les
murs et les frontières monsieur risson
demandez-le un tout petit peu obtus
rebours plus comme on dit dans mon pays
même un gros bonhomme a cantonné à petit
au bout en fait c'est le morceau dans
tout le monde dans tout le sauciflard si
je peux me passer cette expression un
peu familière et trivial mais ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire et tout le
monde comprend ça veut dire que nous
allons demander aux opérateurs en
contrepartie d'être nos investisseurs
d'intérêt général et on va essayer
d'éviter les doublons on va optimiser le
câble existant
après tout soyons intelligents on va
essayer le faire en sorte que chacun se
répartissent on va utiliser
finalement l'avis du conseil de la
concurrence sur la mutualisation des
moyens voilà c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que nous allons continuer ce
travail avec vous je vais laisser la
parole à axel le maire pour qu'elles
donnent les voies les moyens les d'état
qui répondent plus précisément mais
voilà notre vision politique
juste une petite remarque pendant que
madame le maire se prépare l'adisq sûr
que nous avons eue lors des auditions
c'était que en gros ce qui nous a été
dit en tous les cas dans les zones
denses et que la mutualisation et tel
cancer
qu'il n'allait pas survivre si on leur
imposait la mutualisation
j'aimerais bien comprendre ce qu'il ya
là derrière c'est bien ce qu'on nous a
dit aux auditions pierre et donc madame
la ministre vous avez la parole
oui il m'arrive d'écouter bien
d'abord pour répondre aux interrogations
soulevées par monsieur le sénateur
pierre hérisson
vous parlez de la complémentarité entre
le rôle de l'état des collectivités
d'une part et le secteur privé de
l'autre et c'est bien cette
complémentarité qui est au coeur de
l'esprit du plan france très haut débit
et de dire cela ce n'est pas faire
preuve de naïveté
naturellement il faut maximiser
l'investissement des opérateurs
privés est de toute façon dans le plan
tel qu'il a été défini et ça reste vrai
aujourd'hui c'est l'investissement privé
qui porte l'essentiel de l'effort et il
n'y a pas de remise en cause du plan en
ce sens seulement le gouvernement
reste et doit rester très vigilant sur
les engagements pris par les opérateurs
c'est notamment vrai pour
numericable sfr à ce titre par exemple
je vois monsieur drei ce jeudi et 7
cette question ce sera sera bien bien
entendu au coeur de notre de notre
discussion mais il serait difficile de
pousser tellement les opérateurs à
s'engager fermement sur les
investissements sans que le gouvernement
n'entendent les difficultés rencontrées
par les opérateurs en ce moment du fait
de la diminution de leurs marges donc
nous devons aussi les aider dans la
faculté dans la dans la la nécessité de
retrouver des marges c'est la raison
pour laquelle je crois qu'il faut comme
il faut avoir une vision très européenne
de ce sujet dorénavant on a on parle des
concentrations dans le secteur en france
mais la question se pose aussi des
concentrations au niveau européen c'est
un gala merkel qui pose la question
d'ailleurs étonnamment où paradoxalement
puisqu'elle remet elle même en cause et
pour la première fois la manière de
l'autre droit de la concurrence a été
appliquée au niveau européen en
considérant que cela a affaibli la
position de nos acteurs industriels dans
le secteur des télécoms il ya une
crainte qui réel que nos opérateurs
prennent du retard dans le déploiement
des infrastructures notamment par
rapport aux états unis et à l'asie il
faut à la fois entendre cette crainte et
puis en même temps peut-on la
relativiser un petit peu parce que le
taux d'effort des opérateurs c'est à
dire leurs investissements ramener à
leur chiffre d'affaires il est
comparable à celui des opérateurs
américains ce qui conduit à un niveau
d'investissement qui est en réalité en
forte progression depuis les trois
dernières années
mais cet effort je les dis doit être
maintenu et doit être amplifiée pour
cela il doit être financé sa pose la
question de la soutenabilité dans un
contexte de baisse des revenus donc la
cedh ou là d'où le sujet de la
stabilisation du secteur et de sa
concentration de la mutualisation des
infrastructures c'est dans ce contexte
qu'ils sont essentiels pour que les
opérateurs retrouvent les marges
nécessaires et pour faciliter leur
investissement et bien nous encourageant
le partage de la charge d'investissement
prévus pour le déploiement de la fibre
et nous encourageons le recours à la
mutualisation des réseaux mobiles
cela étant dit
je continue à penser que le problème que
vous avez identifié il est somme toute
circonscrit et il faut pas le surestimer
nous parlons non pas des zones où
l'investissement est déjà présent où les
loups alors roulé les garanties les
engagements sont très fermé ne seront
pas remises en cause au contraire qu'ils
sont les zones très denses nous ne
parlons pas des zones
d'intervention publique nous parlons des
zones d'amis qui sont des zones
relativement moins dense dans les zones
d'initiatives privées qui sont elles non
câblées cela concerne approximativement
mais à vue n'ait 4 à 5 millions de
prises soit environ 1500 communes et
c'est là que la vigilance toute
particulière
de l'état doit s'exprimer et qui est des
moyens de financement
nouveaux peuvent être trouvées pour
permettre d'accompagner les opérateurs
télécoms dans l'ordre dans leurs efforts
d'investissement soyez assurés que le
gouvernement très très actif sur ce
sujet monsieur le sénateur yves rome
vous avez parlé de la nécessité de
consolider les engagements de l'état sur
les 3,3 milliards d'euros qui ont été
annoncées je puis vous assurer que ces
engagements sont fermées je comprends
tout à fait votre soucis et vous avez
raison de vouloir les retrouver dans le
dur de la loi budgétaire
donc je m'assurerai donc que cet
engagement est non seulement tenu mais
lisible rapidement au plan budgétaire le
président de la république s'y étant
engagé et arnaud montebourg et moi même
veillons à la mise en oeuvre de cet
engagement budgétaire vous avez aussi
exprimé des inquiétudes quant à la
gouvernance notamment des syndicats
mixtes ouverts dans le cadre de la
réforme des territoires qu'ils soient
départements ou régions alors le la
le plan au fil des années a su s'adapter
à
des changements institutionnels qui que
ce soit les fusions d'agglomération les
communautés de communes les ont
finalement été assez nombreux il fallait
tout de même
répondre à cette préoccupation
particulière du statut jei ces mots
notamment du fait de certaines
configurations en bretagne par exemple
ou une région s'engage sur
l'exploitation du réseau et que les
départements individuellement se sont
engagés sur la construction des
infrastructures avec une division donc
infrastructures et exploitation du
réseau et c'est du fait de ce type de
configuration
que il avait été décrétée par le
ministère de l'intérieur à travers la la
la la direction générale des
collectivités locales que la compétence
n'est pas ces câbles ce principe selon
lequel la compétence des territoires
n'est pas 5 ces câbles il va se
retrouver dans le projet de loi
décentralisation simplement avec une
exception qui concerne les syndicats
mixtes ouverts lorsque ceux ci sont
d'envergure départementale aux
régionales il ya déjà une prime aux
projets dans le cadre du plan très haut
débit qui ont fait l'effort qui doit
être saluée et reconnue par l'état de
de réunir les compétences
entre départements pour accéder à des
niveaux d'échelle de mise en oeuvre du
plan qui permette d'être suffisamment
intéressant notamment pour les
opérateurs télécoms pour attirer leurs
leurs investissements et bien
c'est cédant pour répondre à cette
préoccupation toute particulière que la
loi va introduire une exception à la
destination des dés
dès ses mots lorsque un conseil général
ou une région et membre du syndicat
mixte donc dans ce cas là il est
possible que le sm bénéficie d'une
délégation de tout ou partie de la
compétence mais ces sujets seront soumis
à discussion parlementaire dans le cadre
de l'examen de la
de la loi sur la décentralisation
finalement la question du feder elle est
là aussi essentiel parce que nous avons
parlé des des sources de financement en
provenance des opérateurs privés nous
avons parlé dès l'engagement des
collectivités locales de celui de l'état
il y à aussi celui qui vient de l'europe
et le fonds du feder visant à un
aménagement équilibré des territoires à
l'échelle européenne joue un rôle
essentiel en cela il est vrai que l'état
compte beaucoup sur le soutien du feder
pour la mise en oeuvre du plan très haut
débit vous poser cette question parce
que
un commissaire européen a
émis l'idée que ce n'est plus le feder
mais le feader donc le fonds agricole
qui pourrait être appelé à financer le
plan france très haut débit et de
manière générale tous les plans de
déploiement de l'internet dans l'est
dans les territoires nationaux alors sur
ce sujet le gouvernement a
entendu les préoccupations que vous avez
soulevés qui sont très légitimes nous en
avons fait part rapidement à la
commission avec d'ailleurs je tiens le
souligner le soutien très actif de la
commissaire en charge du numérique nelly
crous sur ce sujet
la décision
devrait nous être favorable sans que je
sois à ce jour en mesure de la confirmer
totalement il semble en tout cas que la
question de la nécessité de pouvoir
utiliser le feder au moment d'examiner
les projets soumis dans le cadre du plan
france très haut débit soit de nouveau
ouverte donc c'est une avancée
importante sachez en tout cas que le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé sur
le sujet je n'exclus pas de me rendre à
bruxelles pour rencontrer les
commissaires concernés si des nouvelles
contraire aux nouvelles assez
rassurantes reçu récemment devait tomber
merci monsieur leroy
oui on vous écoute en
madame l'hommisme se vide je suis à la
fois rassurée inquiet je voudrais
rappeler qu' il ya dix ans j'étais à
l'origine avec eux un de mes collègues
de normandie du de l'article de loi qui
permet aux collectivités locales de
s'engager dans comme opérateur opérateur
d'opérateurs installateurs de
l'infrastructure dans le but
d'éviter la fracture numérique la dd des
zones les moins peuplées le sans parler
d'autres problèmes de fracture mais
c'était ça bien l'idée aujourd'hui les
technologies ont évolué et il ya
toujours un risque de fracture numérique
et ce risque n'est
en partie par cette idée de la mixité
technologique
moi j'ai rien contre la mixité
technologique au jeu la pratique dans
mon département où on utilise toutes les
techniques y compris satellitaires mais
si on on ne va pas en dessous en
soubassement de nos stratégies
d'infrastructures l'idée d'aboutir le
plus rapidement possible à la fibre
optique pour tous comme on l'a fait pour
la fibre en cuivre nous allons courir et
nous courons vers un nouveau risque de
fracture numérique d'autant plus et vous
l'ap vous l'avez rappelé monsieur nice
d'autant plus que les besoins en débit
en quantité de données vont augmenter
considérablement
non pas seulement de la part des
individus et les entreprises mais de la
part des systèmes d'objets connectés
qu'on dit et donc les zones rurales or
on veut les mêmes besoins en
infrastructures et en techno j que les
zones urbaines dont je me méfie et ses
jeux j'ai suis à moitié rassuré en vous
écoutant il faut que le soubassement
reste vient
l'infrastructure en fibre optique le
plus rapidement la face aux grands fibre
optique avec pau et pour tous le plus
rapidement possible et si possible pour
tous c'est fondamental sinon on va se
perdre on va se perdre dans des
facilités qui feront en sorte qu on va
installer le provisoire pour longtemps
et qu'on aura des zones à l'abandon
voilà je suis j'aimerais que vous le
répéter monsieur le ministre pour qui
ait pas confusion le quai pas confusion
en disant oh oh zones rurales
écoutez vous aurez peut-être quelque
chose mais rassurez-vous le mobile la 4g
la 5g la cij et vous permettront de vous
passer d'un réseau fixe alors qu'on sait
bien qui a pas il ya nécessairement la
présence d'un réseau fixe puissant pour
soutenir un réseau itinérant un réseau
mobile puissant le no président
d'ailleurs va rencontrer ce problème
avec ce système d'antennes il nous faut
vraiment la fibre optique partout pour
tous pour éviter au maximum le sien si
on veut passer aux problèmes de santé
novelli tout se tient ma deuxième
question
en dehors des assurances que je souhaite
c'est que nous allons effectivement
devoir
reconsidérer un peu la façon de
mobiliser le plan national haut débit et
nous allons devoir a aussi un peu
reconsidérer la façon dont on traite les
réseaux câblés jusqu'à présent les
réseaux câblés n'était jamais traité et
du mois traité par dessous la jambe et
d'ailleurs numericable qui aujourd'hui
eux étant même à la tête de d'un réseau
de télédiffusion sur un très grand
nombre de français c'est énorme le
réseau numérique c'est un réseau de
télédistribution qui est en train
progressivement de
muter en un réseau de télécommunication
et donc il aurait le quel est le statut
juridique à terme de
numericable est ce que numericable doit
s'ouvrir à la concurrence est-ce que
numericable devrait être régulée
régulé par l'arcep le voilà des
questions
jusqu'à présent on s'en était jamais
soucié mais aujourd'hui numericable en
rachetant sfr et sur ses propres réseaux
est en train de monter un vrai réseau
haut débit sur son câble est
probablement s'il est associé à sfr va
freiner sait faire oui il ya toute une
série le freiner sait faire dans ses
investissements de c'est évident et
réfléchissez un peu donc monsieur le
ministre madame le ministre d'accord ne
se réunisse francs second quel est le
statut moi je ne suis pas un homme
violent pour les statuts mais quel est
le status de de numericable
maintenant gilles arcens vis-à-vis des
télécommunications c'est un vrai
opérateur de télécommunications
merci monsieur le ministre je crois que
vous avez une contrainte horaire mais
avant vous souhaitiez prendre la parole
oui je voudrais
rappeler un salon bhr de choses que axel
le maire déjà fort bien exposé
vous dire que notre objectif c'est pour
tous et si nous demandons aux opérateurs
la fibre pour tous si nous demandons aux
opérateurs
un effort d'investissement si nous
mettons tant d'énergie à préserver ce
secteur le réguler de façon intelligente
malgré une arcep qui a débit une vision
idéologique que j'ai maintes fois
critiqué et condamné publiquement ce qui
nous a au moins permis nous ministres en
charge du numérique de la communication
d'obtenir le silence d'une autorité
régulatrice qui se prenait pour le
ministre chacun son métier le parlement
contrôle gouvernement agit l'autorité
indépendante réguler mais qui définit
les choix politiques c'est encore ceux
qui sont élus par suffrage universel ou
qui sont nommés sous le contrôle de ceux
qui sont élus aux régionales siens les
moutons doivent être gardés au bon
endroit à l'église restera ainsi au
milieu alors ça c'est des formules un
peu sénatoriales
ça c'est pas gagné vu l'état des églises
un
bel sont toujours au lieu du village
même si parfois il n'ya pas les crédits
pour les rénover alors trêve de
plaisanterie je veux répondre sur l'euro
en disant c'est notre objectif
nous avons besoin
d'alliés d'organiser l'alliance entre
argent public
investissements privés dans l'argent
public collectivités locales argent
européen agents de l'état dans les
investisseurs privés tout le monde et si
avec ça on n'est pas capable de couvrir
la france entière c'est que nous serions
man show donc notre objectif c'est de le
faire comment nous allons faire bon va
s'unir dans un outil plus collectif où
on va se répartir les efforts c'est ça
l'état de notre réflexion nous dit oui
mais attention bon voilà la première
réponse réponse à votre poids de la
question au maire 20 ou en étant avec le
câble ça complique les choses il est
vrai que les engagements qui ont été
pris par les opérateurs ne sont pas
respectées aujourd'hui malgré leur bonne
volonté que je ne remets pas en question
pourquoi mais parce qu'ils sont la
guerre entre eux et qui ils ont pas les
marges pour investir donc à part orange
qui arrive à suivre vous avez une
interruption du service public délégué
de la fibre au
par l'investissement privé aux
opérateurs c'est comme ça qu'on pouvait
l'appeler leur demande de participer à
l'intérêt général qui est aussi leur
intérêt eh bien ils sont interrompus sur
le territoire donc nous notre souhait
c'est que ces investissements reprennent
voilà donc c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que nous travaillons je voudrais ajouter
que la sphère du câble
ne ne nous empêche pas de nous poser ses
questions donc nous avons
décortiqué en effet les problèmes de
concurrence sur le capcom en effet ceux
qui n'accèdent pas aux cas pourraient y
accéder
alors que eux ont des demandes
concurrentiel ce sont des points que
nous avons soulevés je le rappelle dans
la bagarre pour sfr entre numericable et
bouygues le goût ce n'est pas pour rien
que gouvernement a pris une position
très claire et très ferme on nous
reproche parce que le board de vivendi a
pris une autre décision mais cette
affaire n'est toujours pas terminée il
ya des problèmes de dette il ya des
problèmes technologiques
il y aura peut-être des problèmes de
concurrence donc ces questions elles
sont devant nous ils sont pas derrière
nous et le gouvernement défend l'intérêt
de tous les français il ne prend pas des
positions en fonction d'intérêts privés
voilà parfois l'intérêt général coïncide
avec certains intérêts privés parfois
pas en tout cas notre position est une
position d'intérêt général dont nous
avons dit c'est pas l'intérêt général
qu'on se retrouve dans cette situation
et d'ailleurs on le voit aujourd'hui et
on ne va cesser de le voir donc c'est à
maintenant aux opérateurs de prendre
leurs responsabilités et nous serons les
leur rappeler voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire monsieur le sénateur je prie
la commission de bien vouloir accepter
ou excuser mon départ madame le maire va
pouvoir
poursuivre l'audition en vous remerciant
infiniment de votre tolérance
merci monsieur le ministre de parole
était monsieur dit l'un
monsieur le président
mais maintenant je vais me poser la
question au cadam le nerf dans le propos
introductif que vous n'avez pas de du
ministre montebourg
le ministre a fait très clairement
référence à l'échelle européenne puisque
dans les comparaisons entre le nombre
d'opérateurs par habitant et l'unité de
compte si je puis dire était la centaine
de millions d'habitants
or une des conclusions jeux tiers au
moins des auditions que nous qu'elle
nous avons pratiqué que nous avons
pratiqué c'est que les opérateurs là
dans leurs grandes manoeuvres ont une
vision mais alors strictement hexagonal
et l'europe l'échelle européen est
complètement sorti des radars donc moi
je suis un petit peu inquiet puisque en
plus
on nous dit et je le comprends que
l'aménagement du territoire sera fait
aussi et peut-être même surtout par les
investissements que le secteur privé
capable de mettre donc la question est
ce que vous pensez pas alors monsieur
montebourg a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
être intrusif effectivement mais ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il est souhaitable
de favoriser l'échelle européenne de
façon à effectivement avoir des
capacités d'investissement et
d'aménagement des territoires plus forte
merci madame le ministre
et en même temps peut-être une
conclusion
monsieur le sénateur leroy vous avez
parlé vous avez parlé du risque de
fracture numérique et
nous sommes très conscients de ce risque
c'est même l'objet même de la
définition et de la mise en oeuvre du
plan france très haut débit que de créer
un cadre dans lequel tous les acteurs
amené à jouer un rôle dans le
développement d'internet peuvent se
confronter leurs stratégies afin que
celle ci se fasse au bénéfice de la
couverture du territoire dans son
ensemble donc le alors est loin de moi
l'idée de minimiser le risque que vous
que vous soulevez il existe en
particulier dans les zones blanches et
l'identification des zones blanches elle
est ancienne et elle appelle l est pas
né avec la naissance du dernier plan
français au débit annoncé en 2012
aujourd'hui je crois que sur les zones
blanches le temps peut-être venue d'un
bilan
par rapport aux engagements qui date
d'il ya plus de dix ans est ce que
on peut
commune par commune situés dans des
zones blanches c'est à dire vraiment
très mal couvertes et très mal desservi
essayer de voir où on en est par exemple
mais même sur une couverture toute
basique en 2g on est on est très loin de
la question du déploiement de la fibre
mais je crois que ce bilan là aussi qui
se veut très pragmatique et kinés loigne
en rien de l'objectif technologique du
déploiement de la fibre est nécessaire
doit être doit être
fait je donne un exemple avec les
rapprochements de communes des objectifs
pour les zones blanches qui avaient été
fixés il ya dix ans concernant un bourg
avec une obligation de couverture du
centre-ville de du centre bourg et bien
avec des rapprochements de communes ans
s'est rendu compte que le second bourg
qui avait été qui avait été fusionnées
n'était plus dans l'objectif de
couverture de ces zones blanches donc
avec des zones des trous avec des zones
vides voilà donc ça c'est eux c'est une
je crois que c'est un travail qui doit
être qui doit être entamée vous parler
du risque de fracture numérique
j'aimerais aussi parler du risque de
fracture sociale parce qu'on en parle
mon plus rarement lorsque on parle de
télécoms or aujourd'hui sans doute plus
encore qu'hier
l'impossibilité d'accéder à l'outil
internet est source de grande exclusion
et de est facteur de discrimination
notamment pour la réinsertion sociale et
pour la recherche d'emploi ce n'est pas
un hasard si environ 20 % des français
n'ont pas accès à internet et ce chiffre
double donc monte à 40 pour les ceux de
nos concitoyens qui touchent moins de
900 euros par mois d'où l'intérêt de
lier la question du déploiement de la
fibre dans des tuyaux en des
infrastructures avec celle des usages ce
n'est pas un hasard si mon conseiller
télécom c'est en charge des réseaux de
communications électroniques et de
l'inclusion numérique
aussi parce que je considère que l'état
comme les collectivités comme les
opérateurs télécoms ont un rôle à jouer
dans la diffusion des usages pour que
internet soient plus facilement
accessible à tous cela dit je suis
désolé si je ne vous ai pas totalement
rassuré l'heure de dire de constater que
certaines zones restent reste des zones
absolument non couvertes et de dire que
là où il ya déjà beaucoup de câbles là
où il ya du cuivre là où il ya de la 4g
peut-être que il faut au moins jouer sur
la concurrence des infrastructures et
avoir une approche plus rationnelle du
déploiement de la fibre
ça ne remet en aucune manche en cause
l'objectif de la fibre déployée à
l'échelle du territoire d'ici 2023 cet
objectif n'est pas remise en cause
monsieur montebourg vous l'a dit je le
répète c'est important de l'entendre
vous avez une question a été posée sur
la régulation du câble le statut de
numericable alors effectivement il faut
des règles équitables quelles que soient
les infrastructures de très haut débit
en cause que ce soit le câble ou la
fibre et sur les investissements de
numericable plus spécifiquement dans la
fibre fibre nous devons faire confirmer
les intentions de la société et
notamment confirmer les engagements pris
dans la zone a mis par
sfr le statut de numericable c'est une
question ouverte pour le moment
effectivement l'entreprise n'est pas
soumise à la même réglementation que les
autres opérateurs donc il faudra
se poser cette question vous avez raison
de la poser une question sur les
concentrations en europe il y a à la
fois un discours de la part des
opérateurs or télécoms français qui est
de dire si
nos réductions de marge sont aussi
drastiques alors même que nous étions
des champions industriels ya dix ans
c'est notamment parce que l'europe n'a
pas eu de vision industrielle pour les
télécoms et que nous avons été rattrapés
par des stratégies de concentration
d'autres opérateurs étrangers ou
l'arrivée des plateformes du numérique
il arrivait de services et des usages à
destination des consommateurs finaux
avec un certain déni quant à ne pas du
fait de nos formidables capacités de
déployer toutes sortes de technologies
pour par le biais des infrastructures
pour apporter pour apporter internet
c'est vrai c'est vrai maintenant
je crois que le temps est venu pour la
commission européenne pour les
gouvernements comme pour les opérateurs
de faire ce constat ensemble pour
justement essayer de décliner une
stratégie de concentration au niveau
européen et c'est un discours que je
tiens à l'égard de mes interlocuteurs
français comme à l'égard des instances
communautaires à ce titre la décision
qui a été prise par la commission
européenne concernant les concentrations
dans le secteur des télécoms en
allemagne et en irlande on peut penser
que a priori
le passage de nouveau à trois opérateurs
est perçue d'un oeil favorable c'est
plutôt une bonne
nouvelle si l'enjeu est effectivement de
consolider les marges des opérateurs et
d'avoir une stratégie européenne
cela dit quand on regarde la les
décisions la fin là la décision prise
par la commission
j'ai cru comprendre que des conditions
étaient posées qui sont en réalité très
rigide et qui place la barre très haute
par exemple il faut que une capacité
soit laissé aux opérateurs virtuels
donc à des opérateurs qui ne dispose pas
de réseau à l'heure actuelle de pouvoir
intégrer ce réseau donc ça veut dire que
tout opérateur doit avoir le droit
d'utiliser l'espace public hertzien
dans le cadre des concentrations annoncé
mais qu'il faut quand même laissé une
partie de cet espace public à des
opérateurs qui pourraient arriver sur le
marché donc l'idée c'est que on autorise
3 mais avec l'idée qu'un quatrième doit
pouvoir rentrer alors est ce qui a un
effet vertueux au plan de la théorie
économique
selon lequel les règles de concurrence
la simple perspective de la potentielle
arrivée d'un autre opérateur suffit à
modifier le comportement des acteurs
cela reste à vérifier seconde condition
posée par la commission européenne si je
ne m'abuse il faut que des fréquences
puissent être cédées aux nouveaux
entrants potentiels donc là encore
l'idée est laissée ouverte de l'entrée
de potentiel entre ans quand on dit et
angela merkel dit qu'il faut revoir les
règles de la concurrence au niveau
européen pour moi c'en est
l'illustration parfaite
j'aurais aussi pu parler de lait des
règles de la concurrence qui s'applique
à l'heure actuelle aux opérateurs
télécoms et non pas aux plateformes
numériques
dans ce qu'on appelle les géants du web
2.0 qui sont généralement très
généralement
exclusivement américain
et qui déploient des services dans une
vision dans une stratégie industrielle
horizontal et échappent en cela à
l'application des règles de la
concurrence telles qu'elles sont
appliquées en tout cas aux opérateurs
télécoms traditionnel donc je crois que
le temps est venu du déploiement d'une
stratégie industrielle
mais pour cela il faut que les états
soient très avenant et ça sera le cas du
gouvernement français face à la future
commission européenne qui doit être
formée à l'automne mais aussi des
opérateurs télécoms privée donc soyez
assurés que ce discours que je tiens
devant vous aujourd'hui je le tiens à
l'adresse de tous les acteurs privés que
je suis amené à rencontrer pour moi
c'est absolument essentiel si l'on veut
utiliser au mieux les 505 millions
d'utilisateurs qui se trouvent sur le
territoire européen
quand on sait que les opérateurs
américains bénéficient de la même force
de frappe chez eux
merci madame nous tous les cas sans
doute ne nous reverrons dans le cade
d'une proposition de loi bientôt qui
vous concernera
au moins dans le domaine du numérique je
parle du titre 2 de la ppl ondes sur les
15 meilleurs devons nous rencontrer
madame si vous voulez bien m'accorder
rendez vous
je suis sûr que nous aurons des choses à
vous proposer
merci en tous les cas tous ceux qui sont
restés mais ce sont les meilleurs
forcément
et donc à demain aux membres de la
commission
vous êtes donc pu suivre les auditions
d'arnaud montebourg est d'axer le maire
devant la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat sur les questions
de numérique et de téléphonie mobile
tout de suite la suite de nos programmes
sur public sénat